哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
今天又來到了十分鐘心理學
那我想跟大家分享的其實是
我最近有在我的粉專上講到
我看到了一支影片
然後看了非常有感覺
那就是
如果今天我們被人家羞辱
被酸民就是批評啊等等的時候
我們要怎麼樣可以讓自己好過一點
那那一支影片對我來說
我印象非常深刻就是
雖然我自己平常也會做這樣的事情
可是我覺得他用非常簡單的方式
告訴我們一件事
他就說因為在那支影片裡面的主角
他自己也是一個
就是蠻多人會追蹤他的人
那他就說那個時候呢
他看到了別人的批評啊
他就會很認真的去回應人家
結果呢
很喜歡他的粉絲就傳了一個訊息給他
就跟他說
我常常說我很愛你
我很喜歡你的東西
可是你從來沒有回應過我
但是呢
那個他可能連追蹤你都沒有
但是他隨便批評你一句
就可以花掉你這麼多的注意力
大概是這樣
然後他就說
他看到這個訊息的時候
他的感受就是覺得
啊
so shame
就是很羞愧
就覺得好丟臉我怎麼會這個樣子
可是這件事情其實非常非常容易發生
為什麼呢
因為我們之前其實有跟大家討論到
就是講到焦慮啊
我有些集數在講內耗
這件事情是一個非常重要的關鍵
那就是我們大腦很習慣會去找威脅
怎麼說找威脅
那就是別人批評我是個威脅
別人可能會傷害我是個威脅
別人說我不夠好這個東西是個威脅
尤其是如果你小時候
哎這個時候又要講到小時候
不過這大腦的確是就是這樣長大的
也就說你從小常常會被提醒說
哎一定要常常自省
要常常看看自己有沒有什麼地方有問題
然後呢不可以都把錯怪在別人身上
你要不停的檢討自己
你從小就是跟著這個價值觀長大的
這件事情
只要遇到現在日常生活中
有人批評你的時候
你的大腦有時候沒有辦法
正確的去判斷這個批評本身合不合理
你的大腦它的那個習慣的框架呢
會直接就先有一個習慣
叫做我就先看看是不是我有問題
甚至一直反芻
哦他現在批評我
可是我明明不是像他講的這樣
那會不會其實我可能真的有這樣
我自己不知道呢
我就會花很多很多時間
去把一個隨便別人射過來的箭喔
然後一直放在心上一直折磨自己
這其實就是內耗的根源
我覺得這件事情非常麻煩
那個麻煩就是因為
大腦會很容易在意威脅
很大的原因
當然它就是因為焦慮
而它焦慮的時候
它就會更在意威脅
這個東西就是雞生蛋蛋生雞
如果它很有安全感
它反而比較能夠忽略這個威脅
它就會覺得
哦可是我現在很安全啊
所以這個不用太在意
很像是你在一個超級安全的堡壘中
然後下面可能會有人會攻進來
或是會有水什麼的
可是你非常清楚
這個堡壘超級超級安全
你一點都不擔心
所以你就不會有不安全感
你也不會一直去想說
啊我會不會什麼地方漏掉了
會不會什麼地方就有人會攻進來
沒有 因為你超有安全感
可是大家有沒有覺得這件事情很難
我們怎麼可能超有安全感
沒有錯
當你的大腦很習慣要放大那個威脅
以避免受到傷害的時候
我甚至有時候會把它
形容成是一個受過創傷的大腦
因為忽略這個威脅
甚至是這個威脅我根本來不及忽略
我就被傷害的很嚴重
我曾經經歷到很嚴重的威脅
在這個情況之下
我幾乎很難告訴自己說
其實這個威脅不注意也沒關係
因為我的經驗是
沒有 那個威脅都會傷害我
我是很脆弱的
這個世界是很不安全的
這也是我在關係黑洞裡面有講到了
安全感這件事情
其實關乎於我對我自己的看法
我有沒有能力讓自己安全
我對他人的看法
他人會不會威脅我
還有我對世界的看法
世界會不會傷害我
如果這些看法我都覺得我是很脆弱的
這個他人一定都會傷害我
就是幾乎都是敵意的
這個世界呢也是傷害我
不會有什麼好事發生在我身上
我就不會相信
今天如果我有一件事情沒有注意到
這個事情不會發生成很糟糕的事情
因此遇到別人的批評
我一定要把它放大
這是很容易會發生的事情
但是這又出現另外一個狀況
那就是
大家可以想像一下嘛
如果你想像就是我們跟人家打仗
有人就是拿箭射你
那他沒有射中就掉在地上對吧
如果你把言語想像成是箭
他射向你是為了要幹嘛
為了要讓你變好
當然不是啊
他射向你就是為了要傷害你啊
我覺得那種講話
變成是很傷害的言語的箭
然後把這個話當成是
別人為我好這件事情
我覺得這是
我們亞洲文化最大的陷阱
因為我們都會誤以為
人家是為你好才要這樣講你
不然他幹嘛花時間在你身上
哦
no
不是這樣的
因為
如果今天他批評你
你就會被他影響
例如說你是
人緣很好的人
你是名人
你是有一些成就表現的人
他隨便一句話就可以得到你的注意力
隨便一句話就可以影響你
哎這個是一個控制感欸
我可以不用花太大的成本
我也不用負責任
我隨便講一句話
就可以傷害你就可以影響你
就可以改變你
這是一個權利的感覺
這多好
所以說他幹嘛要花時間在你身上
因為花時間在你身上
可以讓我很有成就感啊
那我為什麼不做
這個成本真的是低成本生意
所以這句話其實是不合邏輯
各位朋友
所以如果有人再跟你講說
這個人他會跟你這樣講話
是因為他是為你好
不然他幹嘛花時間在你身上
請你把這個邏輯跟他說
還有再分享那個
批評跟指導是不一樣的那一集給他聽哦
就是我們前面都有講這個東西
所以這件事情非常困難
但是你看哦
如果是實體上的箭
他射向你
然後呢沒射中掉在地上
你一定烙跑吧
可是最麻煩是言語的箭
如果我們把它包裝成別人會這樣對你
其實是為你好
所以那個箭是很重要的
就是你不但要把它留著
沒戳到你的話
你還要帶回去照三餐戳自己
然後你把自己戳完之後
就很大一洞
然後就去心理諮商
然後問心理師說
哎這個洞怎麼那麼大
哎就是我們常常會做的事情
可是那是因為我們就是很Ｍ嗎
我們很自虐嗎
我們為什麼總是要拿別人的劍
來傷害我們自己
我覺得這件事情非常大的困難
第一個就是我剛剛說的嗎
我們對威脅的那個敏感度
第二就是我剛剛說的
我們對於別人傷害我們的話的包容度
亞洲文化就是會用說
啊他其實是為你好
所以我們為了不要不好
為了不要不自省
所以我們就會誤以為那個話
我們再噁心再難聽再難吃我們都要吞下去
我才會健康
不
不是
它不是一個讓你健康
但不好吃的東西
它是一個會傷害你的箭
我們沒有辦法分辨這件事情
然後第三
因為我們很焦慮我們要找事情做
所以當我今天沒有機會
可以很有安全感的相信自己的時候
我們相信別人傳達事情的時候
我們會想要傷害自己
那個拿箭虐待自己的時候
其實某方面也是會有一種自虐的快感哦
因為某方面來說就是
我至少好像有做一點事情
也就是我做這件事情
至少我在檢討我自己了
那我應該就不會不好了吧
我應該就會進步了吧
然後另外一個部分是
如果我相信我真的不夠好
我拿那個箭刺自己的時候
就是那樣不夠好的我
是需要受到傷害的
所以我會做這件事情
而這個東西就很像
我在停止內耗課程裡面講的
反芻的一個狀況
而這個東西我在羞辱創傷裡面也有講到
它是一個羞辱
而並不是一個對我們
狀況很好的一個建議
一個指導
可是當我們今天一直以為
那一個供給對我們來說很重要
原本他對我們的重要性非常低
我們把我們的力氣全部花在他身上的時候
他就變成那個真的重要的人
他就變成那個有資格傷害我們的人
可是你知道嗎
他為什麼有資格傷害你
那個傷害還有那個資格是你給他的
這件事情可能有些人會說
所以我被傷害我還要怪自己嗎
不是這個意思
這件事情有一個非常重要的關鍵是
我們認為
如果今天我不把注意力放在他身上
我就會有危險嘛
所以我就要把注意力放在他身上
可是很有可能他其實真的是一個
不需要我們花注意力的人
可是我們大腦不敢放
不是不放
是不敢
因為我們以前學到的都是
我一定要把這一些所有的威脅都去掉才行
我要100%確認我是安全的才行
很多的人常常有被傷害的經驗
你的不安全感很大
你很少有被保護的經驗
你不能了解
所謂的安全感不是在於沒有任何威脅
所謂的安全感其實在於
你願意站在你自己這一邊保護你自己
自己隔開所有威脅
所以不是消除所有威脅
是你要保護你自己隔開所有威脅
這是非常非常重要的
可是如果我們不是用這樣的習慣的話
我們就很容易會誤會
我們既會把威脅帶到自己的保護圈中
然後我們又不懂得
在遇到被傷害的時候去篩選
哪些東西對我真的是有用的
哪些東西純粹對我是傷害我
因為我沒有保護自己的能力
所以我連篩選都不敢
這是一個非常重要的
一個對我們最大的影響
所以我們回到威脅這件事情
剛剛我們講大腦會放大威脅
所以我們大腦會有些習慣性的反應
例如遇到攻擊的時候我們防衛
或是剛剛我說的反芻
或者是我反而會一直去搜尋他
所以這些事情全部都會
放大這個人對我的影響力
所以回到最終就是
我想要鼓勵大家
你會說
今天誰誰誰說了我一句話
我真的覺得很難受
我真的不想要放心在這件事情上
但是我真的沒有辦法怎麼辦
我會鼓勵你
我們有很多就是幫助你大腦比較減緩
有很多在講焦慮的一些書
或是我的課程也好
或是其他網路上有非常多影片
我之前十分鐘心理學講很多焦慮的部分
請你練習不反應
這件事情非常重要
練習不要馬上反應
練習不要馬上收下
練習先讓你自己用保護的模式
隔開這一個傷害
讓你有機會篩選
只要你能夠不要馬上吸收
不要馬上反應
它就讓你的大腦多一點選擇
這個是我們最想做的事情
第二個
我覺得對我非常有幫助的方法
就是建造我的安全感
我自己的安全感堡壘
我在早期的時候
我幾乎是好的訊息不好的訊息
我都不一定會回
後來有的時候我會回
批評或是不好的訊息
但是好的訊息我也不一定會回
但在過了一段時間之後我就覺得
哎其實有這麼多人願意留言鼓勵我
支持我
祝福我
他們大可不用花這個時間
可是他們會想告訴我
我的書對他們的影響
或是我的文章對他們的影響
或是Podcast對他們的影響
YT對他們的影響
我覺得我是一個很幸運的人
所以我想要一則一則的回覆他們
去感受我的幸運
然後當我一則一則回覆的時候
我跟他們就是一個人的連結
而這個連結對我來說是一個我的保護傘
那就是提醒我
就是在我經營社群的過程中
一定會有不喜歡我
甚至會故意想傷害我的人
可是也有這些
他們跟我非親非故
只想告訴我他們是支持我的
他是信任我的
他是愛我的
而我想要花力氣
在這一些有光跟溫暖的地方
我想要放下那一些
就我就是故意來射箭的
我就是故意來傷害你的
我就要看你有沒有被我刺到
被刺到我就賺到了
而如果今天我會被刺到
除了有可能是因為我就是
敵在暗我在明
有可能是因為這樣之外
還有一個可能是
他射箭的東西可能就是
我自己有點沒把握的部分
我有點沒有安全感的部分
我有點心虛的部分
那或許在這樣的情況之下
怎麼樣把那一些我沒有安全感的部分
或是我在意的部分補起來
會比我要不要說服這個人能夠相信我
或是肯定我
或是跟他去辯論來的更重要
因為有可能他射我的地方
可能是我不夠的地方
但是很有可能
我很坦然我不在乎
這個東西就是不夠的
所謂不在乎是因為我知道這個不夠
能補就補
沒補的話現在我就長這樣
不然你咬我啊笨蛋
差不多這種感覺
但是如果今天我希望我要十全十美
我站在大家面前我是一個很完美
不能讓人家說出任何批評的人
某方面來說
我覺得這也是一種驕傲欸
那就是你
假設你做的每件事情都是perfect
這其實是很不合理的對吧
然後另外一個部分
也是為了要達到這個目的
你會犧牲掉很多東西
你會付出掉很多自己
最後呢
你還會就是
可能會讓你不敢前進
或是不敢成長
因為你可能會擔心
只要有人給你一些比較正向的提議或建議
你可能就會擔心那是不是我不夠好
而不會看到你還有什麼地方
可以再幫助你自己去更進步
去看到更不一樣的自己跟世界
我覺得這是很可惜的地方
好啦今天談到
要怎麼樣可以就是
讓你把注意力拉回自己身上
那其實與其說是要教大家怎麼做
倒不如讓大家重新去思考
我怎麼會把注意力放在這樣的事情上
不是你不對哦
而是我自己為什麼會這麼做
所以最後提醒大家
如果你發現你很容易
因為別人的一個批評
然後一直過度反芻
要把注意力抽回來
先問自己三個問題
第一個問題
他是我生命中重要的人嗎
第二個問題
他的意見值得我投入時間嗎
第三個問題
我願意讓他的惡意決定我的一整天嗎
好
所以當你問你這三個問題的時候
也許你會有一些屬於你自己的答案
而你的感受跟心情或許會有所不同
好的那麼今天周慕姿放心說
跟大家分享的這個主題
希望大家喜歡
那麼我們下次見嘍
掰掰